je sais plus comment il fait et puis si
tu y arrives je t'offre un téléphone
portable voilà alors moi
et forcément je vais gagner un téléphone
portable alors je vais je vais essayer
devant vous de faire le F sans repasser
sur le même train
je me rappelle un jour j'avais été voir
mon père à l'hôpital et en partant le
soir il passait l'émission sur RTL dans
laquelle je passais une quinzaine
d'années et donc je vais faire un espèce
de longue travelling avec toutes les
télévisions et regarder tous l'émission
qui a marqué et je voyais tous les
petits lits comme ça avec les draps
blancs et les ventres qui faisaient
comme ça il rigolait en regardant un
truc et je me suis dit au moins je sers
à quelque chose déjà parce qu'on se
demande toujours à quoi on sait et je me
suis dit il faut jamais que je fasse mal
à quelqu'un
[Musique]
est-ce que je fais bien l'accent belge
OK
c'est incroyable de dire devant moi qui
n'est plus beau non là tu fais exprès de
tu détournes le truc
la différence entre un carrefour à sens
giratoire et un rond-point
dans le rond-point tu t'arrêtes le
carrefour à son giratoire non et il
habite la plupart des gens appelle le
carrefour giratoire un rond-point alors
que c'est pas du tout ça j'adore
conduire
[Musique]